I'm going to Belfast for a week and then
ice them for two weeks I'm so grateful I
want to get the opportunity to come to
these places there are so many quality
shows on television that I love and
admire but I don't think there's one
with the scale of Game of Thrones just
look at that in terms of the numbers in
terms of the size of the cast in terms
of number of countries we shoot in and
it's simply huge you feel so incredibly
lucky as an actor you come in and it is
such a brilliantly well-oiled machine I
don't think Game of Thrones is like
anything anybody's ever experienced it
it is its own Beast not only do you have
nearly 600 script pages but you've got
six different directors and five
different DPS and you've got 19 weeks of
shoot using two parallel units it is
madness these scripts this season by far
are my favorite not just for me but her
for all the characters and you don't
have to figure it out when you think you
do the challenge was to keep the story
fuelled with action and energy and
surprises and they've introduced some
new characters from new cities whole new
plot elements that taken together
surpass success for the first three
seasons brilliantly it feels fantastic
to be back during the fourth season of
the show show that keeps expanding every
year every year you're visiting
not just new locations in the same world
but new societies and new cultures
what's so exciting about the season is
that yes it's epic yes
since sprawling for me this season the
story just gets more intense and complex
it's a wonderful show to do the script
are impeccable we have terrific
directors dare I say bloody good actors
and absolutely compelling storylines
[Music]